[Música]
en que pensamos cuando pensamos en
ciudad
qué es lo que viene a su cabeza cuando
yo digo la palabra ciudad que es lo
primero que viene a su cabeza si me
pueden ayudar por favor
gente que más
edificios victoria que más
algo más nada viene a su cabeza cuando
yo digo la palabra ciudad
pintura carros agua ok
problemática de la ciudad ok
servicios públicos cuando yo digo la
palabra ciudad por lo general en el top
of mine de las personas casi siempre me
dicen servicios públicos
me dicen nombres de políticos me dicen
los nombres de las ciudades me dicen
capital del mundo me dicen que las
flotas son de harina etcétera muchas
cosas bien en la cabeza cuando yo digo
la palabra la palabra ciudad
pero casi nunca la primera palabra que
viene a la cabeza es ciudadano o
ciudadana
por lo general hay una diferencia muy
importante entre las palabras habitante
y ciudadano o ciudadana cada país lo en
su marco legal lo pone de manera muy
diferentes si nosotros nos vamos como
una manera legal pues cuando yo paso a
ser ciudadano o ciudadana es cuando yo
tengo ya la mayoría de edad sin embargo
para mí hay tres diferencias que
demuestran la diferencia entre habitante
y ciudadano ciudadana
como por lo general un habitante casi
siempre se queja constantemente de todo
y lo anuncia y lo dice y lo publica en
redes sociales y un ciudadano y una
ciudadana por lo general pues lo que
hace sí es observar pero también lo
denuncia se informa en las instancias en
donde puede denunciar lo que está viendo
lo que está observando la otra
diferencia es que el habitante o la
habitante que está habitando su espacio
es que no sé no conoce a sus vecinos no
conoce quiénes son sus políticos quién
los representan
quién está como presidente o como
diputado en su congreso del estado por
lo general no lo conoce y un ciudadano
se informa conoce un poquito más acerca
de esto
otra diferencia muy importante es que un
habitante no participa dentro de lo
político porque cree que pues no importa
que es algo más o no no no se hace no se
involucra dentro de los espacios que
puede involucrarse o no conoce
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
donde puede desarrollarse un poco más y
un ciudadano y una ciudadana si
ciudadano ciudadana se informa y
participa constantemente es un agente de
cambio esa es para mí de manera muy
personal y si ustedes leen libros acerca
de participación ciudadana no son - es
lo que van a encontrar es una diferencia
importante más allá de cumplir la
mayoría de edad pues es cuando ya vienen
los derechos pero también las
obligaciones verdad entonces
pues cuando pasa esto y que yo ya me
vuelvo ciudadano o ciudadano quiero
pasar de habitantes a ciudadanos que va
más allá mucha gente me pregunta ok de
mí es bueno todavía sé acerca de
participación ciudadana pero que más que
más puede pasar o en lo que yo les digo
es encuentren a otras personas con su
causa personal amor y hablaba ahorita de
algo muy importante y vimos que la
motivada y había una palabra muy
importante que yo creo puede resumir y
sobre todo reflejar lo que humor y
sentía aquí que es indignación cuando
nosotros encontramos lo que nos indigna
lo que nos molesta lo que nos entristece
podemos entonces encontrar nuestra causa
personal y cuando encontramos nuestra
causa personal podemos encontrar a otras
personas que yo me imagino que aquí
dentro del auditorio de la gente que nos
está viendo puede existir más personas
con nuestras causas personales y
entonces podemos hacer una sociedad
civil fuerte organizada
encontrar y hacer organizaciones de la
sociedad civil ya constituidas y quiero
ponerles unas cifras de cómo está méxico
en temas de la organización de la
sociedad civil el indesol la última
cifra que nos da en junio del 2016 nos
dice que son alrededor o un poquito más
de 33 mil organizaciones de la sociedad
civil la secretaria de hacienda y
crédito público nos dice que alrededor
de 8 mil por ahí veía 8000
y esto es en méxico a nivel nacional
como anda tamaulipas como andamos en
temas de organización de la sociedad
civil tamaulipas es el estado con menos
organizaciones de la sociedad civil es
el estado con menos organizaciones de la
sociedad civil en promedio son 11 por
cada 100.000 habitantes si hacemos una
regla de 3 y les digo yo que hay
alrededor de 3 millones 440 mil
habitantes en tamaulipas cuantas creen
ustedes que hay en tamaulipas
organizando la sociedad civil
340 más o menos 345 por ahí vamos a
darle un redondeo son muy pocas en
ciudad de méxico son más de 2000
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
en oaxaca de juárez son alrededor de
2000 organizaciones de la sociedad civil
y si nos vamos un poquito más allá a
compararnos como anda méxico con otros
países comparándolo
eeuu tiene 670 organizaciones de la
sociedad civil por cada 100.000
habitantes méxico tiene 27
o sea estamos muy abajo
pero qué pasa o sea porque estas cifras
se les traigo porque por lo general nos
comparamos como en todo pasa es normal
somos seres humanos nos comparamos y
empezamos a decir oye porque mi ciudad
está así cómo está mi estado está como
está
mi méxico está como está porque a es que
tenemos estos políticos
es que está tal partido gobernando
no pues es que los servicios públicos
casi siempre es esta es la respuesta al
momento de compararnos pero como al
principio cuando yo les preguntaba qué
es lo primero que viene a su cabeza
cuando yo digo la palabra ciudad y que
ustedes mencionan servicios públicos y
políticos y problemas del agua etcétera
se nos olvida algo muy importante que la
palabra ciudadano y ciudadana
y que no se nos olvide que los
ciudadanos y las ciudadanas hacemos la
ciudadanía y que debemos haber más
ciudadanos siendo ciudadanos que
ciudadanos siendo habitantes muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]